but I think that 10 years from now if
we've done the wrong thing if we haven't
changed then this country is going to be
a complete you know economic wasteland
hi I'm Matt Welch editor-in-chief of
Reason magazine and I'm delighted to be
here today with Peter Schiff the man who
predicted more than any other single
commentator the current financial crisis
he's also the president of euro pacific
capital he is possibly the next senator
from the great state of Connecticut
thanks for joining us thanks for having
me tell us a bit about so this potential
chris dodd challenge well first i have
to challenge the other Republicans
running for the nomination so if I can
repeat them then I get to run against
Chris Dodd but what I've done so far as
I've done some polling I've hired some
consultants I set up a website now on
behalf of my exploratory committee which
is shift for Senate calm and I am you
know asking people to make donations and
hopefully sometime within the next few
weeks I might decide to officially
announce and one of the factors that is
going to strongly influenced that
decision is the number of people who
donate and how much they donate because
this is going to be an expensive race
I'm gonna need a lot of money I'll spend
some of my own money but I'm gonna need
a lot of help from other people what
would a senator chef want to do it would
you be your priorities upon well the
number one thing to do is stop what the
government is doing now I mean we're in
a gigantic hole the last thing we want
to do is keep digging it deeper so
you're there in September of 2008 and
your Treasury secretary and everyone
comes in and says AIG is blowing up that
we're going to have the next great
depression is happening right now you
got to do something what do you do in
that moment well you know I understand
the problem and so I let age AIG go
bankrupt and I probably fire that
secretary of the Treasury if we had not
bailed out AIG and let AIG go bankrupt
and of course let Goldman Sachs go
bankrupt and everybody else at AIG own
load money too we would have had a sharp
or downturn than one that we have but
you know what we would already be
solving the problem because we'd be
confronting it and dealing with it all
we're doing now is postponing
it and making it worse so there is no
recovery anywhere in sight ten years
what's the dollar going to look like um
well I mean it's not going to be the
reserve currency you know that's for
sure and so and the dollar is not going
to buy nearly as much as it does today
that whether it buys nothing at all you
know whether we go down the path of
Zimbabwe and I gave him a speech today
and we were taught we had a hundred
trillion dollar note in my hand in order
to avoid that fate we're going to have
to make some serious changes in our
policy because right now that's where
we're headed and hopefully our cooler
heads will prevail before it gets that
bad if we can implement the necessary
reforms and 10 years from now you know
will already be you know well into a
recovery but between now and then
there's going to be a substantial
downshift than the american standard of
living I mean that's the reality because
of the Fed because of all the policies
we pursued we've lived beyond our means
we've allowed the real wealth producing
industrial part of our economy to
disintegrate and we simply spent money
like drunken sailors and we run up
trillion-dollar deaths and we've got
nothing to show for it and we're going
to have to tone for that we're going to
lower regulations we're gonna need less
government spending so we can have lower
taxes we're gonna have to have a much
higher savings rate which means people
are gonna have to earn money and not
spend it and so we're going to have to
go through this transition but if we do
all the right things then we will build
a sound foundation and have a bright
future finally what's a nice ein of Hope
out there a little green shoots sticking
up it well there's no green shoots now I
mean but in terms of possibly changing
policies changing mentalities in the
direction that you would find well
there's hope but there's not hope based
on anything that's happening it's just
hope to be optimistic but right now
there's no actual signs that you can
point to as being hopeful I mean
potentially if i can get elected to the
Senate that would be a reason to be
hopeful if i can actually get there and
talk some sense in everybody but if I
can't if I'm just one voice in 100 and
and all I can do is talk until I'm blue
in the face and they just continue on
this path then said it's going to be a
real disaster well I'm not very hopeful
note
we will end for reason TV thank you to
peter schiff and i am Matt Welch have a
excellent afternoon
you